el río de janeiro no va a ver carnaval
ni en febrero ni en julio o el alcalde
eduardo paes ha anunciado que con las
cifras de contagios y de muertos por la
pandemia es imposible celebrar una
fiesta que conlleva una enorme
aglomeración recordamos que el año
pasado el carnaval atrajo a más de 2
millones de turistas el alcalde es
conocido por su pasión carnavalesca
incluso toca varios instrumentos de
percusión y hoy en sus redes sociales ha
dicho que entiende la importancia
cultural y económica de este evento que
el año pasado generó una facturación de
745 millones de dólares sin embargo
algunas representantes de las escuelas
de samba están molestas con el alcalde
por no ofrecer una alternativa económica
porque muchas de esas personas se han
quedado sin sustento en el año más duro
del siglo es un sector que en la mejor
época o sea el alta estación genera
cerca de 8 mil 500 empleos directos e
indirectos y ahora mismo está
completamente parado el alcalde ha dicho
que espera
se puede realizar en 2022 el carnaval de
forma normal ya todos vacunados pero hay
que recordar que la vacunación que
empezó esta semana todavía va lenta por
falta de dosis